[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un buitbouuit bien cranau où
les mecs par-dessus le calandau se
rincent la cloison au cou chef maison un
bordeau pas piqué des anenton temps en
temps il y a un vieux pull à sueur qui
s'offre un vieux jambon au vieux beurre
et puis une nana une jolie drôesse qui
promet des monceaux de caresse
oh
boyau le patron s'appelle
Bruno il a de la graisse plein
laétif des gros points noirs sur le pif
en Bruno fait le menu et le sert dans
les premières douleurs au dessert
l'estomac à genou qui demande pardon les
boyaux qui tricotent des naprons les
rotules de grandmère c'est du beurre à
côté du bifte pomme va beur si avant
d'entrer il te reste une molaire un
conseil tu la laisses au
[Musique]
vestiayau le patron s'appelle
Bruno sa femme est morte il y a 3 mois
de
nulcestomin dans le quartier même le
mois le plus doux tu ne risques pas
d'entendre miaou des greffier mignon il
y en a plus BF ils sont tous devenusin
du chef je viendrait longtemps d'un
gazier qui voulait à tout prix du giier
il chuta avant de sucer les EAU les
moustaches en croix sur le carreau oh
tortbyau le patron s'appelle Bruno il
envoie des
postillons ça fait des yeux dans le
bouillon sois prudent prends bien garde
au fromage son camambert a eu le retour
d'âge
avant de l'approcher je te jure que tu
hésites ou alors c'est que tu as de la
sinusite comme Bruno a un gros panarie
le médecin prescrit le bain marie mais
sutissement en t'amenant l'assiette il
le glisse au chaud dans la
[Musique]
blanquettey le patron s'appelle
Bruno rien qu'à hum
mirontonas la gueule pleine de bouton il
s'agit d'un bouiboui bien crado où les
mecs par-dessus le Calando sur un la
cloison au cou de chef maison un bordeau
pas piqué des anon cet endroit est
tellement sympathique il y a déjà le
tout Paris qui rpplique un petit peu
déçu pas être invité ni filmé par les
actualité
auy le patron appelle
Brunau allez vite le voir
avant qu'il s'achète la tour
[Musique]
d'ARD